hi my name is Magnus I'm with the Google
Drive team we're going to look at the
asus Wi-Fi go technology which allows
you to interact with your Google Drive
content from anywhere and also remotely
control your computer let's have a look
people around the world manage their
files every day share store email
collaborate do you carry it around with
you it's no longer an option when data
is so valuable how do you manage backups
or real-time collaboration recent
research shows that 45% of web users use
cloud storage with so many cloud storage
options available though transferring
files around can be a hassle and
time-consuming tasks how to help users
manage them is an important topic that
developers have been working on for some
time our users taught us that a new way
to synchronize their stuff between
different cloud services we want to help
them do all that and even more so we
give up control as part of our Wi-Fi go
package to offer an integrated tool for
post commandment and the media streaming
we want to make it easy to use fast and
reliable so that's why Google Drive is
our first choice Google Drive delivers
the tool that we need to create an
reliable integrated cloud storage it
also helps us understand how calcio is
experienced by our users so that we can
continue with our passion building the
innovative features and making them as
good as they can possibly be in
designing HD software our goal was to
make the behavior and interface as
simple and clear as possible now we can
see on the screen is our Wi-Fi call
Wi-Fi go is a free software utility
available on App Store and Google Play
we can see under manual here it includes
many remote control features such as
multimedia streaming or a remote desktop
2 remote control your PC now let's have
a look at that couple
so this is cargos main interface on the
top are the passkey functions here you
can browse and select files to upload to
storage down low create folders and
editing which are all easy to use how to
sing them all across the cows or even
pick up
simply click the file and select the cow
you want and take back up to PC then
it's all done here you can see the data
is also storing your PC at same time
overall the application aims to provide
house users and integrated platform to
manage synchronize and backup files from
one point to another providing greater
benefit in this new cow storage area